what do you think about the mop at this
point of your life you've been around it
yeah you get a lot of uh sometimes
people
i mean you've read it you've seen it
you've you this is you it's your life
people claim you were part of it like
maybe there was some affinity to it a
connection to it but what are your
thoughts when you think about the mob
well the mob is not what it once was
that's for sure it's kind of like all
fractured
you know it's not what it once was and
what was it i mean
could you say it one time it was
there was real on them yeah probably
maybe the old timers there was but
what's what's the benefit of
of shaking down your own neighborhood
and people have to pay you money i don't
i don't know you know
it comes down to what my dad said
real respect real
real people who are real men
go out and they get a job and they work
for a living take care of their family
that's a real man he goes he said it
doesn't take much strength to pull a
trigger but get up in the morning every
day
so i see them i
do i admire them now i have do i i still
see them and now i have fun with them
when i see them i laugh i talk
but
i i
i respect my dad you know i respect the
guy who gets out and and make and works
and works hard a working man is not a
sucker the working man is not a sucker
no he's not
he's not look everybody in the wise guy
that i knew ended up dead or in jail
so if somebody told you if you walk out
that door every time you walk out that
door you're going to get hit in the head
with a bag of garbage you stop walking
out that door yeah but these guys keep
walking out that door yeah
they know they're going to keep walking
that's part of that fascination because
that life kind of doesn't exist anymore
these were kind of like the modern
pirates this is the wild west this is
jesse james it's romantic looking back
at it and saying wow these guys took
life by the horns they did whatever they
wanted to do and nobody could say
anything right but if you lived with
them if you lived with that type of
person it had to be a hard life to deal
with that well the movies were romantic
they have terrible lives they have
terrible lives their kids are always
forget it
if they're not there with their children
their kids end up bad
i mean i'll tell you i'll tell you a
story about a a big wise guy in my
neighborhood well he i i don't want to
mention his name
um
but his son
his son became a wise guy he wasn't made
of his son yet he ended up getting made
uh no i'm sorry he never got mad he was
so crazy and i'm sitting there i'm
standing there with a priest my best
friend
and this guy this wise guy on the corner
his son is walking up the block his son
was maybe 20. okay son is going now i
could curse right i mean of course yeah
and his son's walking up i go [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that and he's gonna i don't give
and he's talking to another guy [ __ ]
that
and and i and and it's like there's a
priest right there he walks he was like
hey dad what the [ __ ] and his father
goes what's the matter what the hell is
wrong with you
he goes the [ __ ] guy just
he pulled the [ __ ] with me in the scam
he goes i swear to god don i'm going to
shoot him i'm going to kill him i'm
going to kill him and his father
standing right there goes quote
the hell is the matter with you
you're saying things like that in front
of people so i'm saying to myself oh
he's gonna
you know reprimand his son right you
don't ever say things like that what's
wrong with you because if you're to
whack somebody don't stay in front of
anybody
which is good advice
this is a father
talking and i was like
did he just say that i was like
there was a priest there and we both
looked at each other like
did he just say that
if you're going to whack somebody you
keep your mouth shut i'll talk i'll be
with you guys in one minute and walks
away with this kid
now
what shot does this kid got what
happened to him well that value at 20
years old 20 years old what happened to
this kid yeah killed three people
life life in prison he ended up killing
three people killed two guys and then he
killed a guy in jail
he's gone jesus what you could you
expect different how he grew up
right you're expecting the father to be
like you don't do that what's wrong with
you
if you're going to do that you don't
tell nobody you keep it alone
and i was crazy i was like
did you see anybody did you see anybody
that was able to have a normal life or
no
yeah my friends no on the mob side maid
man mob side you know no okay no ever no
the number runners some of the number
runners yeah i knew them
the past the father to the seventh to
the center yeah and they had just normal
lives but they were just number ones
yeah look sal romano was here yesterday
he said something he says you know
you know why everybody eventually uh
flips and they go cooperate i said what
he says if the mob did one thing nobody
would ever cooperate i'm like what is
that he says if they
he says we're not afraid of going to
jail we're not afraid of going away we
already understand that that's part of
it every one of us has done a little bit
of time i'm like let me see what this
guy's going to be saying he says if the
mob had a program to take care of the
wives and kids when you went away nobody
would cooperate that's [ __ ] yeah
that's what he i'm just telling you what
he's [ __ ] okay so that is [ __ ]
tell me why because it's [ __ ]
because they're just trying to justify
why they can't wait to get they all sing
this as soon as they get caught they
have run they race to the d.a who's
going to make the deal first it's
[ __ ] listen my my friend you saw
rudy giuliani one of my closest friends
worked for him and rudy knows him very
well
and i'll tell you who he is name is phil
foley he passed away my closest friend
would covet when covert happened i still
breaks my heart anyway
phil told me with these wise guys
because he he worked with rudy put him
all away he's just one wise guy goes
into his office right
he's sitting down at the chair of course
phil is going to speak to him about you
know flipping
so he goes listen now you want to make a
deal with me and blah blah blah
i don't think phil told me he's a story
he goes the guy just sits back and goes
well you know phil
i don't know what i want to do i got to
think about my future those were the
words he said
my friend phil gets up
right there's two detectives in the room
with him he says come here come here
picks the guy up grabs him by his arm
come here come over to the window brings
him over to the window and says look you
see that sun over there you see the sun
right he goes the next time you see that
sun is going to be the year 2040
2040 that's when you're going to see it
because i'm going to put you the [ __ ]
away for 40 to 50 years now get the [ __ ]
out of my office
they brought him out of the office 10
minutes later he came back he goes i'm
sorry i will make it they made a deal
come on stop it when somebody's telling
you you're going to sit in a box
for 40 years 50 years you talk it's got
nothing to do he's full of [ __ ]
uh there are so that's that's
i
i mean obviously that's why i wanted to
ask you but there's some people that
uh look at rudy and they say rudy as an
italian how the hell you put so many
people away as an italian you put away
your own people yeah and they went to
jail you you did this with the rico law
all this stuff that you go through
what do you think about rudy with what
he did in the 80s to the mob i think
rudy was great
yeah i mean look i mean i got gotta be
honest with you when he came to my
neighborhood they booed him
they you know they didn't like him yeah
it was you know
because
you know but was is rudy a good man yeah
yeah he put people away these guys are
bad guys yes
you know don't get me wrong i hung out
with them but i didn't become a wise guy
i don't want to be a wise guy they're
bad guys they'll they're the first ones
to tell you that
you know
you know are there some stand-up guys
who don't rat yeah benny eggs the
old-timers guys like that francies yeah
they didn't rat you know that's it they
don't rat and okay but that's a if you
want to go that listen john gotti didn't
rat
say what you want about john gotti he
was a gangster to the end
to the end
you know i'm not i'm not saying but but
at least
he stood by his code and said no this is
it
this is it a guy told me a great story i
won't tell you who he was
but when when god he was on his uh on
his on his dead bed
when he was dying from throat cancer
a priest walked in
and the person whispered
to john
you know there's a
priest here
do you want the priest to and and john
went like this
right to the end man no he already made
his decision he already made his
decision no no he didn't want to give
any final words no i don't know if it's
i don't know how do you interpret it
like i don't need a priest i made my
decision but do you think he's saying i
don't need a priest or do you think he's
saying
there's no way i'm going to have a spot
in heaven like there's no way i don't
get it how do you think you process that
i don't think he was even thinking that
yeah got it i don't think at that moment
i can't like is it like i can't i don't
know
i never met him but i think a wise guy
was just saying like nah you know i
don't want to deal with it it looks like
i'm i'm giving up at the end not not to
give the audience too much here but
there's a gentleman in mafia states of
america that may disagree with with this
sentiment no no question about it i mean
obviously there's a part of it that uh
you know
some on the other side who
from sami's camp may say in the
recording john did kind of throw
sammy under the bus saying he was going
to have somebody take him out so there
was that i i don't know about that again
those things i don't know about yeah all
i know is the guy didn't rat you know
you know what be a great sit down you
know it'll be a great sit down yeah you
know it would be a great sit down
uh junior and sammy would be great sit
down yeah that would be cool i don't
know about it we wouldn't need to have a
fence we would need to have uh that
would be but that would be a great sit
down i think that one john gotti
john gotti oh yeah because because let
both of them
hash it out in front of the world
and talk to one another now the
likelihood of that happening that's
that's but you're not going to get it
look you're not going to get an answer
you're not going to get a truthful
answer but what would happen is you know
what would happen is is uh
i'm a big fan of a good debate yeah you
know what does a good debate do we don't
necessarily end up getting an answer but
we get a little closer to the truth
right a good debate because you watch
body language you see one person backing
down you see one person gets nervous you
see one person really gets annoyed when
you poke him in an area that's like
listen you don't poke you can poke me
anywhere this one everyone after this
person we learn a lot so i don't know
i'm not telling you it's gonna happen
the likelihood is
but i'm just saying that would be that
would be something i i don't know uh i
don't know if that could happen i don't
think neither junior nor sammy would
agree to do that sit down i don't think
they would i think there's too much
water under the bridge i think so i
think they couldn't even talk about
certain things yeah now if it did happen
how crazy would that be if it did happen
if it did happen we would we would
probably need to get uh you know
national guard there we would probably
need to get the
military there we probably need to call
yeah some security yeah i just don't
think it could happen yeah now the
setting too is very very important right
like you were talking about you know
rudy and who who talked who didn't talk
right the new york you grew up in is so
different from the new york people know
today especially in the bronx yeah the
bronx was burning back in the day i mean
you were 60s and 70s in the bronx there
was a five alarm fire every day they
were trying to burn the tenants out so
you know then in the the late 70s late
70s was son of sam right i mean like the
new york you grew up in
a lot of times i hear the stories it
feels like it was a little bit of a war
zone man
it was crazy time but i have to say i
didn't have i had a great childhood i
had a wonderful childhood so people
always go my god the childhood i go no
no it was great you know the wise guys
ran the neighborhood we were all tying
our kids growing up well everybody was
italian in the name but it was great so
i can't say i didn't have to me it
didn't look like
like bad you know race riots the bomb
there's no race riots in my neighborhood
there was none there was everybody was
italian there
but it was our turf you know like bronze
tale we owned that and then uh the black
zone from where webster avenue was the
puerto rican zone in a different area so
you stayed in our area reggie jackson
thurman munson i mean come on chris yeah
yesterday chas is at the house and tikko
and dylan are like hi how are you i said
do you know who he is no i say he's a
very very famous actor really what movie
were you in
just like having a conversation and i
say bronx tell i said do you think it's
time for them to watch bronx tale chad
says how's your son i said tico's nine
years old he says you know that's how it
was when i saw a guy get shot right in
front of me i said they're probably
ready to watch bronx sale
i know when will you let the kids watch
listen we've already watched movies they
shouldn't watch so we'll probably be
ready we just haven't had the time to
watch
what six seven dylan is seven yeah you
know what and i never noticed that about
that until i had a son and then when my
son became nine
i turned to my wife i never forgot and i
said i said janna you know
dante and dante my son grew up in
bedford you know
you know so i look at him and i go he
was i was that age yeah and it was like
weird to me great childhood when i see a
child who's a child who's nine or ten
years old i look and i go
how could i be at that age seeing what i
was crazy right it was crazy crazy can i
ask more of a light-hearted question
here yeah we were talking about it last
women again are you gonna we're gonna go
to women we're gonna go to women okay
how'd you know
so well you talked about you know the
girl the black or you know let's stay
here before we go there because that's
like a complete right again on the 95
freeway let's stay on a1a4 stay there
kai can you pull up the video about
giuliani before we take the street for
uh because adam's trying to learn about
women i have a question you want to
learn about them go to my podcast
charles military show there it is i talk
about the women all the time
by the way kai put the link to his
podcast in the comment section as well
as the
description folks go subscribe to chad's
podcast uh you do this how often you do
show how often i do a new show each week
each week
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you